because of those rising numbers recently
nevada is waking up to new restrictions
right now
while we don't have new shutdowns like
some states businesses were forced to
cut capacity
at midnight so both private and public
gatherings
also have been cut down kate houston is
live with us today with how local
businesses are
trying to prepare for even more changes
hi kate
hi good morning yes this pause is
affecting a variety of areas from the
casino floors here on the las vegas
strip
to even inside the comfort of your own
home and this is all in an effort
to slow the spread of clovid 19 here in
nevada now these new restrictions
will reduce capacity limits to 25 or 50
people whichever is less
this will impact establishments such as
restaurants bars and gyms
for restaurants this will apply to both
indoor and outdoor dining
they will be under strict social
distancing guidelines
and these restrictions are creating some
more uncertainty for restaurant owners
during a year when
some even had to shut down due to the
pandemic rodrigo ibarra runs operations
for
don tortaco which had to take out a loan
in march to stay afloat
he says he will need to cut staff hours
and depend on food delivery services
over the next few weeks
i wouldn't say we're okay with it but
kind of like rules are rules
we do kind of question their decisions
on how they want to do all these things
support your local business aside from
you know helping the business you're
also helping it keep it open and when
those people when it's open they can
keep their employees
employed these restrictions will also
apply to private gatherings such as
thanksgiving which is in two days
private celebrations will be limited to
10 people or less
from no more than two households and
this three-week pause
does not affect retail stores it also
doesn't affect any sort of personal
services such as nail salons
or hair salons you will still need to
wear a mask when you're in
any sort of public or private gathering
space reporting live from the las vegas
strip this morning kcs
8 news now